[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson happy friday we opened the show
last night with a kind of dark segment
on the looming war between russia and
ukraine a bipartisan coalition of
neocons in washington has been
recklessly stoking conflict between
those two countries for years now our
foreign policy establishment in fact has
sent hundreds of millions of dollars in
weapons to one of the most volatile
regions in the world hoping for some
kind of explosion and now their wish
seems to be coming true that explosion
looks like it's on its way and it could
very easily suck the united states into
the center of it
that's what we said last night
but honestly as we read those words they
seemed hard to believe
we're really going to fight a war over
some corrupt eastern european country
that is strategically irrelevant to us
with everything else that's going on
right now in our own country
no normal person would ever want to do
anything like that how could it really
happen
we're still not sure how it could happen
but nevertheless it does seem to be
happening right now
the bite administration has begun
evacuating american civilians from
ukraine the pentagon has announced it is
prepared to use force in the region
so this country is now closer to a
legitimate war than we have been in
decades and to be clear we're talking
about an actual war here not a
protracted series of airstrikes against
some impoverished dirt patch they're
telling you as a existential threat to
the nation
russia is not iraq russia has nuclear
weapons and a real army a war with
russia is not a joke it won't be over in
a week
so you'd think right now
might be the time the president of the
united states could explain
what's going on here what exactly are we
doing in eastern europe and why are we
doing it
but no
in an exchange with reporters today joe
biden explained that he wasn't going to
take any questions at all for fear that
someone might ask him about russia
by the way the reason we're not going to
have any time for questions now is these
guys got to get quickly on the plane and
go out and do a major announcement in
ohio and you guys will ask me all about
russia
you guys will ask me all about russia
and joe biden's not falling for that one
again you can see why
a couple of days ago he tried to talk
about russia during a press conference
and he got the talking point so mangled
that his staff had to issue statements
afterward informing us that joe biden
has no idea what he's talking about
biden's mistake at the press conference
was suggesting that maybe war with
russia is not inevitable in washington
you're absolutely not allowed to say
that donald trump said it repeatedly
they impeached him for it in joe biden's
cases handlers just stepped in and told
us a brand new story here's white house
chief of staff and amateur comedian ron
klain explaining that actually this is
what joe biden meant to say and as you
listen to it you may notice that it's
the opposite of what biden actually said
i think it's fair to say the white house
is pretty aggressively walk back or
clarified whatever you want to call it
the president's comments about ukraine
and russia and whether the president was
signaling that a minor incursion
might be viewed through a different lens
whether the president meant to say that
at the time or maybe he was being
inarticulate can you afford any gaffes
given the stakes right now in all this
well i think the president was quite
clear and reiterated his point of view
this morning very clearly president
putin should have no doubt any move by
the russian assembled military across
the border of ukraine is an invasion it
will be met with a very severe economic
response from the united states and our
allies
so this guy called ron clain whoever
that is gets to overrule the president
of the united states on matters of
foreign policy since when is he allowed
to do that
well whenever he feels like it that's
the real answer joe biden is the weakest
leader this country has seen since
woodrow wilson had a stroke in office
that's a problem but it's not the core
problem the core problem is that in
america elected officials no longer
decide when we go to war as in say a
democracy
instead bureaucrats generals and defense
contractors make those decisions
sometimes unilaterally
here's failed rockstar and hilariously
inept secretary of state tony blinken
threatening quote severe action against
russia
discussion today with mr lavrov
was frank
and substantive
i conveyed the position of the united
states and our european allies and
partners
that we stand firmly with ukraine in
support of its sovereignty
and territorial
integrity we've been clear
if any russian military forces move
across ukraine's border
that's a renewed invasion
it will be met with swift
severe and a united response from the
united states
and our partners and allies
so the president united states is not
allowed to talk in public about russia
he's admitted that today he might say
something that averts war
so instead the same people who've lost
the last five wars get to speak for him
do you feel safer
you've got to wonder what voters think
of this actually you don't need to
wonder what they think polls show that
most americans are completely opposed to
fighting russia over ukraine because
they're not demented
but you know who's very much in favor of
it well defense contractors including
pentagon chief lloyd austin's former
employer raytheon
for defense contractors war means
massive profits if by definition in just
the last few years the u.s has spent
more than 2 billion dollars on military
aid to this nation called ukraine that
most people couldn't identify on a map
just the other day excuse me the
administration announced 200 million
more
so the ukrainians love this obviously
this is the whole reason they once
employed joe biden's otherwise
unemployable son to keep the cash
flowing to them
so when biden hinted this week that war
might not be coming right away
the ukrainians were highly distressed in
fact they were so distressed they said
so out loud watch this
the big concern expressed by one
ukrainian official i spoke to last night
is that this offers vladimir putin a
green light in his words to enter
ukraine at his pleasure
so the ukrainians are complaining about
american foreign policy about what the
president said at a press conference the
government of some place called ukraine
is demanding that we fight the russian
army on their behalf
okay i mean it's not crazy you could
kind of see why would they would want
that it's a lot easier than doing it
themselves
the question is we're the united states
so
why are we obeying them
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else